oh oh that was very friendly um thank
you very much for coming out we are we
are honored we're humbled that you guys
would come and listen to a bunch of
idiots talk about about this so without
any further ado we'll jump right into it
today we're going to talk about
XCOM to leading the resistance and we're
gonna talk about basically how it came
about we're going to talk about some of
the more behind-the-scenes stuff about
how we developed it and then of course
we're gonna show and yeah we're gonna
show you guys a little some some new
content that we haven't shown anybody
some new things I guess they haven't
shown anybody so to go around the room
little children
my name is these little children my name
is Jake Solomon I'm the creative
director
I'm Greg furch I'm the art director I'm
Garth DeAngelis I'm the lead producer
and I'm Ryan McFaul on the lead engineer
right so to start with I guess thinking
about where X come to came from you know
obviously we we had this incredible
opportunity because of enemy Unknown but
I guess talking you know when you're
developing something that's that's the
first game you don't really think beyond
that so I think when we were working on
the MN known and enemy Unknown we worked
on for a really long time right great
yeah long time only felt like a century
or two but you know it went really well
and then because of that after enemy
Unknown finished we had this opportunity
to say okay what is it we're doing next
and you know we knew we wanted to make
more XCOM but the question was what do
you do what direction do you go and so
we kind of had a lot of things that we
thought about we could have done a
linear sequel you know where you started
with plasma weapons and you know I don't
want to say anything because then it's
gonna sound you know then people like
yeah you should have done that
so they were all terrible ideas except
for the one that we did go underwater or
whatever but why would you do that
someday no no and so what you know it's
when we played with all those ideas I
think the the corvex come it's a game
about struggle you know it's a game
about humanity that is you know a
humanity that you can recognize facing
these really long odds and facing
enemies that are much superior to you
and seeing the things they have and then
coveting them and trying to get them for
yourself and so then we started thinking
well what's that what is the setting for
that and and you know loss is a really
big part of XCOM you know you lose
soldiers you can lose missions you can
lose games and so we kind of took the
idea of loss and we ran with it and I
don't remember the first time we talked
about that I do I remember they were
very exciting conversations to me like I
remember when that seed was first
planted because you talked about loss so
much there's one of the Keith I'm addict
pillars of XCOM and when we we first
said and there was actually stories with
some of the key developers are one of
our old lead engineers Casey O'Toole he
actually lost the game one of the first
times he played after we hit beta game
was fully playable I remember he called
us in his office with his head down in
shame with the with with the councilman
on the screen mine being might being
mind-controlled
and he was like I lost i legit lost and
one of the person that actually
architected the game lost the game it
was a key thing that fanatically was
very cool for reasons that jake said as
a setting and also mechanically it
happened it happened to some of the best
players so we said what if X come to
started with with you in position of
loss and then that led to all these
conversations about what what what what
could be really cool mechanically and I
remember at first there were some
hesitation because we're like we can't
tell the player they lost right but we
just did we don't know I mean there was
legitimately there was a lot of
hesitation but you know obviously when
we'll put a lot of time you know
probably a lot of people in this room
put a lot of time into the game and they
struggle and then the thing about XCOM
that i think is neat is that the when
you win XCOM it feels very authentic
because you know that loss is just as
possible an outcome so when you win a
game like X comet it feels very
authentic you know it's a great memory
and so now what I say is and I believe
this is that in the universes every time
you started a game of X come you know
it's an alternate universe and so in the
universes where players won all the
games that we won XCOM 2 never happened
and so the idea by necks come to is the
games that we lost we get to go back and
we get to save the worlds that we sort
of left behind and so that that's kind
of the idea and maybe that's how that is
those genius for every that's marketing
yes that's but I mean the idea is that
for us the idea about XCOM 2 is that you
are starting a resistance movement where
XCOM lost the world belongs to the
aliens and now as a player you're
fighting to take the world back and I
think that that was a really exciting
setting for us is because you can stay
generally conventional weapons at the
start of the game and you can face an
enemy that is even more overwhelming
than an enemy unknown where it's their
world and they they rule this entire
world and so what that meant is that we
started to think about what are the
pillars of XCOM because no matter what
the setting is at four axis obviously
our games are built on mechanics you
know we don't come up with a story and
say hey now let's make a game to fit
that and said we say alright whatever
the story is it has to fit the core
mechanics of what the experience is and
and XCOM those pillars are pretty clear
obviously you have the idea of tactical
and strategy so you have this tense
tactical combat where the stakes are
high and then you have a strategic game
that allows the player to sort of expand
and grow their forces and then we always
think about and we sort of added a new
design pillar after an
unknown one thing we wanted to expand on
was the idea of replayability and so you
know we wanted to have an experience
that players would have the same XCOM
experience that they had from enemy
Unknown but be able to jump back into
the game and have brand new experiences
that was a big big push for us one of
the things that was really important to
Jake creatively I remember back early on
enemy Unknown and we talked about this
before
obviously we had these awesome
handcrafted Maps on and me unknown and
one of the things we really wanted to do
was procedural maps so that was one of
your core pillars and that was something
that Gregg the art team the level
designers our first our first feature
that we knew we had to crack that code
early and development these are some
early early screens yes these are these
are the first things that we did as you
can see we're trying to develop with
this this world looks like 20 years in
the future and along with that you can
see the cover placement even even the
concept artists we're jumping in or
understanding how things had to work
what were the mechanics of the game and
then how do we kind of craft this world
around it and so there are some open
places and you can see some some some
cover scattered around and the way that
we were trying to do it in a way that
made sense and also work with the
gameplay and then you know even even the
point we're looking at how high can you
get on a building and you know what were
those structures gonna be and how are
these things going to procedurally
generate and the first time that we did
it I remember once we got it actually
working the very core the very simplest
version of it I was at home playing and
just just kind of loading it up and I
got lost and I was like okay this works
like I did I made the level and I didn't
know where I was and so at that point I
was like this is this is gonna be this
is gonna work it's funny that led to a
good point the team has such inherited
knowledge and experience from enemy
Unknown and the handcrafted portion of
maps and we have these conventions with
cover size and building height that we
were able to parlay to XCOM to but also
making sure with the system that they
developed which completely changed the
pipeline that it did not lead to this
completely random feel where you felt
lost all the time and you didn't know
where you were going you still needed
some some thought and design behind
these levels even though their
procedural they're not going to
random and and we found that there was a
clear fun factor differentiator between
the two and these aren't like concepts
you'd normally see you know a developer
show you like these are these are really
unfinished these are these are
nuts-and-bolts this is the guy
protecting his art here his source but
then we go to the next slide you know
this is the culmination of okay this is
where we got all the stuff that this is
what we think cities are starting to
look like and the vibe for them going
forward and what we're going to push and
this kind of very clean very immaculate
and then it got so sterile that we
started to bring back some some foliage
but bringing back in some really
unnatural ways and again this was one of
the first images that we we showed when
we were teasing the game and I'm not
sure who the super sleuth was that
figured out that those were XCOM
soldiers web sites so the teaser website
the posters are actually from une W in
fact the white one is actually one that
we actually did when we were doing our
GI covers game formal covers a long time
ago and then the other one is I think an
ethereal from something or other some
poster yeah this was in the Advent
whatever the website was and then people
saw the screenshot and then drilled in
and drilled in and then they're like hey
that poster was in one level of enemy
Unknown and I've seen that already too
Mike yeah yes it is and that goes I
think Gabe Newell said and I he said
like the Internet is scary smart like
you cannot tell a lie
you kind of try to pull anything over on
the internet because it is very very
smart so so so this is sort of the alien
these are the city centers that the
aliens have built at the heart of some
of the the urban areas of the game this
is something very different right yeah
so these are and this is exciting from a
gameplay standpoint there's our small
town set and right from the beginning
again goes back this idea is that X
comes in X come to is in the future but
for us future is not far out future
because the player has to have this
connection they have to feel a
connection to the world that they're
fighting
four so if it was too far out in the
future then I think it gets very cold
and you know you can't really form that
emotional connection and what I mean by
that is that XCOM even in the very
original XCOM and intimate unknown you
had this sense of okay you recognize
this gas station even though you know
it's made-up you recognize it as a place
that you could legitimately see out of
your window and so with the small towns
you know we had to balance the really
cold city centers with something like
this and there is nothing more and
that's an actual asset right this is
concept but that playground is in the
game so there's nothing more XCOM than
like watching your soldiers die on the
slide you know so my kids you can see
also again the concept artists are still
they're still on like the system they're
they're thinking about how these things
are going to be working together and how
they're gonna be created now they're
gonna going to procedurally generate and
so you know while we're exploring both
look and feel we're really trying to
stay very true to what are the mechanics
so we didn't build something that we
couldn't actually make it is fun to
fight in houses which is something we
didn't have so it's just something that
is it does feel very XCOM like where
you're you're trading shots in these
small houses and it's a very cool thing
and then it takes us to the wilderness
levels too so we were again looking at
this this image you can see it's really
the same exact shot with almost the same
geo actually the same geo and then and
then we just are basically how would
these things translate from a temperate
environment to an arid environment to a
Tundra environment and that's where we
landed and the cool thing is in the in
the in the previous screen the small
town you know we have the tech that
actually you can have small towns that
are in the temperate environment small
towns that are in a desert environment
small towns that are in a Tundra
environment and so that is when we talk
about procedural levels there's there's
all of that also the you know like the
the biome of like the small town can
change which makes for a lot yeah this
is procedural on top of procedural the
cover and this shot is exactly the same
but the cover will actually change as
well when you go from there
large amount of tech that went into
making this possible so yeah our liaison
here he made all of this happen we're
talking but he he made all artists we
have real-time lighting this time around
in Excel me you we had baked lighting
and so now we have real-time with light
scattering and all sorts of nice effects
that kind of make it look as close to
the baked lighting as possible that we
all know and the lighting is the key I
mean if we couldn't if we couldn't
change lighting and we couldn't do these
different color Keys which wouldn't have
the same power that we have now and so
with switching over to real-time
lighting and it's made a an enormous
difference in our ability to actually
pull this off and now when you go into a
mission and the nighttime in a daytime
it can match that's true
there's no yeah you'd go into the clock
i we did this trick on anybody known
where it was basically like i didn't
that fast forward time or something then
alex cheat you had to XCOM time yeah was
like oh we're it's gonna be night time
map so suddenly the player just loses
six hours and but now yeah everything
matches so you go into maps it'll be
thomas day whether i mean with all the
actual weather patterns in the game do
we we do okay we do actually have
weather patterns sure why not
you know who's gonna know so when we
talk about the design pillars obviously
we wanted to build on both the the
tactical game and the strategy game and
the fun thing about a sequel is that
when you get all the feedback from the
audience that people have played the
game which makes it really big
difference so thank you very much
you guys are pretty integral into the
shape that x come to took and so what we
can do is look at the things that people
liked and look at the areas we can
improve and so with tactical we were
able to add a lot of things to combat
missions and so obviously one of the big
ones is concealment and here we have a
game shot of aliens
blame aliens the the so yeah here we
have we have here is a shot of a soldier
concealed and you know this is how it is
exactly how it looks in game and so you
know your put your soldiers and this
fits with the resistance idea more but
you're allowed to get a alright you're
allowed to get the jump on the aliens
and and it adds this sort of extra
attention to comment the other things I
think one of the other big things we
have we've had a lot but one of the big
things are added was the mission
objectives so now you know enemy Unknown
it was always going there and kill a
bunch of aliens which is fun but now we
have a lot of other things for the
player to do sometimes you have to hack
a workstation sometimes you have to
rescue somebody sometimes you have to go
in there destroy something and at the
same time you are also always still
killing about you aliens we also really
improved overwatch yep so so this is
something internally we call overwatch
2.0 and it's made possible by a lot of
the tech enhancements that we've done in
XCOM 2 so a next time to the game core
can run independently of what's
happening visually and so as a result so
when you confirm the attack the game
knows what's gonna happen for the next
20 seconds or so so we can choreograph
these cinematic moments and so what you
saw in the e3 demo isn't movie magic
it's actually something you'll see as
you're playing a game yeah that's right
I mean it's really cool you get that you
know the camera swings and time slows
down and you'll swing to multiple
soldiers all taking their shots it's
this really cool choreographed thing and
you know the soldiers don't waste their
shots anymore
yep yes you know modders if you want to
add that in you can do that right you
can make it go back to the original
flowers terrible overwatch so ryan was
saying if they're very smart he can you
can see the future with the system that
they have but this is one of those game
dev moments as well it happens
throughout the game where you have these
spikes of like the first time you see
something like this in the game you're
like okay this is this is a legit sequel
feature the work that engineering did
and the way that the cameras move
and the art behind it wanted to see that
all come together it was probably one of
one of my top five wild moments seeing
it again but it actually came out of the
III yeah yeah yes we didn't have this
until the emails
Brian was gonna drive yes the e3 demo
helped accelerate some writings I think
was a little bit of movie magic and I
was like you know we can actually do
this well we should and I did not
[ __ ] I guess that's a good idea
yep so yeah we use previous as a lot in
practice to kind of show what we want it
to be like and so then the engineers
kind of sweeping behind and make it
actually do that yeah when when I make
those I don't necessarily expect the
that to happen but I hope could I hope
and and so yeah we made it and
eventually Ryan actually got that
working later on it was pretty cool this
is another I mean there are so many
additions to tacko combat and loot and
all the different enemies and all the
different objectives but this is another
addition to tactical combat and so this
is the hacking the hacking system and we
may be one of the first developers ever
to add hacking to a game without adding
a minigame so I don't know maybe you
like the hacking minigames honor that's
a positive- I don't know but the idea
here is that you have a class of soldier
that can really take advantage of this
and so there are different things you
can hack throughout the level you can
hack enemies to take control of them
when you're completing objectives a lot
of times you're performing these these
hacks and then you can you can win
certain things that can change combat or
you can have negative feedback that can
actually make combat a little more tough
so you're always weighing that but it's
a another fun feature to combat right
and the you know the other pillar of
course to XCOM is the strategy game and
I think that this was a thing really
based on what's once people are playing
the game you know when we were making
enemy Unknown you just don't know you
don't know is there an audience there
and if there is an audience what's the
what should the experience be and I
think that my gut reaction as a designer
was to hold on really tightly to the
reins and say
want the experience to work like this
and have a particular curve like this
and I think that was successful but what
I think what we saw was that that really
kind of fought the replayability where
people would say well there's a right
thing to do
in XCOM enemy Unknown and I think we all
thought okay how do we make it to where
strategy is more open-ended where you
know it's a little more unpredictable
which is what we talked about and we
sort of let go of the reins on the
design side and said all right let's
make the game a lot more reapered
unpredictable let's give the player a
lot more replayability and and let's
sort of let off the reins and let them
have the experiences they want and
that's sort of manifest itself in
different things there are lots of new
random attributes you can add to weapons
that you make a lot of things that
happen throughout the world are
unpredictable one of them is that the
aliens now now it's not just the player
fighting to win the game on their own
terms
now the aliens can win the game so they
have a wind condition the players a wind
condition and then there are all these
little short-term things that both
players are trying to do so the AI they
have or the aliens or the AI I guess
yeah and it's whatever same thing they
have their short-term goals that you can
find out about and they may want to do
any one of these things and so here we
have they can hunt down XCOM they can
make Advent troopers much tougher some
of their things that they want to do or
secret and so the player has to choose
okay do I head off this dark event as we
call them because if I don't the aliens
are gonna get stronger but at the same
time I need to focus on advancing my
weapons building up the Avenger so
there's this there's definitely a more
unpredictable strategy game where things
happen and you have this network of
territories you're trying to expand to
and it just creates this much more
unpredictable experience in the strategy
there which I think I think we're
definitely happy with oh yes
the hey modding yeah this is we're very
very excited for modding um we want to
again the the audience you know I think
Firaxis is the kind of company where we
only we only exist because of the
loyalty of our audience and we take that
very very very seriously we don't
consider that like oh we just make these
games we put them out there somebody out
there buys them for us it's very much a
back and forth between us and our
audience certainly sibs the same way
XCOM and so obviously what we needed to
do to improve that on XCOM 2 was to put
the game in our audience hands and give
them all the tools that we have to help
us make X come to better so Ryan can
talk about that yeah so I mean are one
of our main goals for X come to modding
was take the minimum barrier for
entrance from super genius down to
normal person so we kind of watched in
morbid fascination the long work crew
kind of hacking our game apart I'm glad
they're making mods and not hacking our
credit cards oh yeah those people are
robots man I I do not know how they were
able to do what they did I know how and
it's kind of scary but you're not you're
not gonna have to do that for X come to
4x mm to you we're providing a toolkit
through Steam that anyone who buys the
game will be able to get it works kind
of like the mod tools for civilization
so you have a visual studio isolated
shelf kind of glue app that can help
they can build the mods build mod
projects and we're also shipping out our
Unreal editor that we use that we use to
build the game and on top of that we're
also giving out the source code the
script source code not the native source
code and and 50 gigabytes of assets that
went into making the game right
yeah the key for us is that you guys
when XCOM 2 comes out you guys have the
same game that we had when we're
developing it you have the same tools
that we have you used the editor that we
use you have all the assets that the
incredible content team created because
we want you guys to help us basically
make X come to better and so very
quickly I think the first things we'll
see will be in levels like little level
parcels as we call them which is what
you build our actual levels out of but
you'll have all the assets and and it's
as as Ryan said it's a huge amount of
assets that you can have and then start
to put things together yeah it's a lot
of napkin holders hands out of trashcan
just all of the parts that go into the
levels people be able to keep bash new
levels pretty quickly yeah all right so
yeah we one of things we wanted to do
with with - we were looking at it we're
getting started I mean we were really
before I go any further you know
XCOM I am super proud of that and super
proud of what the team did visually on
it but as we looked at it moving forward
with engine we had in the baked lighting
and we really wanted to enhance it I
mean XCOM was built as a game that was
kind of inspired by miniatures and we
really wanted to take that and change it
and kind of evolve it like psycho with
teeth but uh but but now we've got you
know action figures of kungfu grip yay
right so we're we've kind of enhanced it
and really wanted to make it a more
immersive than then then you was and
that you know everything felt right I
mean before we had like fake textures
and try to get it to look right now with
the rendering tech the way it is you
know it's it's a much closer visual and
so again you can see the two next to
each other the fidelity differences is
quite a bit quite a bit different
there's a pod reveal from from EU of
moutains and again moving to the new
mouton I think you tell there's a fairly
big difference in the materials I mean
the the soldier there has
fabric looks like fabric and the metal
looks like metal and the carbon fiber
yeah you know okay we wanted that kind
of wet can a moist skin and and and the
tech that Ryan his team put in really
really allowed us to do that and and the
artists I mean this is the same team who
made you honestly the our team and and
it is it is you know just that the tech
the tech advancements that we've had and
the the fidelity enhancements they've
just run with it and every day they make
something cooler and that and that's the
thing is when you're playing the game
like these screenshots are straight out
of it yeah you know Greg just Cathy
strand of the game there that and some
of those use shots are beauty shots and
these are like capped out of the game so
when you're playing
XCOM to like you will you know you'll
look at your soldier and you will be
able to see the different materials and
say oh that's leather and that's plastic
and that's metal it really really is a
very striking difference with you
actually had to go through and actually
look at the screenshots were released
and you know make sure the levels were
right make sure that it was good I mean
literally these are these shots from
from x2 that I'm showing all of the ones
that have been in this our literally
print screen like I have not touched
anything this is exactly how the game
how the game looks on my desktop so but
again you know the the job the team is
done and just increasing the fidelity
and and and that that immersion when you
drop into a glam cam yeah Bruce Willy
found that on the internet actually but
uh but again the character creator you
want to be able to feel your characters
and see them and really identify with
them and again the fidelity difference
here is is enormous I mean we're still
just saying true to you and and things
are a little bit chunky and a little bit
oversized we're not trying to do real
right that's not necessarily going to
merge in point to be a little a little
better and then you get up close
right that's I mean that's the key of
carrot killa it's not fair if we have
all the fun and so so we just want to
make sure and share that with you guys
yeah
oh good this is the exciting part too
it's all exciting but this part we get
to share never-before-seen stuff with
you guys with the show enemies that we
have never announced or shown before and
so we're pretty excited for this here
this is exclusive to for AXA con so here
we have a new Advent unit that that that
big bulky fella there is the shield
there that's an Advent support unit and
so first before we talk about will just
show what they can do
awesome I was like a Final Fantasy move
and what's really cool about the shield
bear is that we have obviously you have
a lot of offensive enemies but the
shield there is a support unit for the
aliens and for admin and so that move
that the shield bear does it basically
creates an energy shield around every
other ally that's near the shield bear
and so whenever you see your shield
berry you're always like you got to take
them out first because if they get the
shield up now every enemy is protected
by an extra layer of energy shield and
so then you really have to take out the
shield bear and they have a lot of hit
points they're hard to take out so once
they get to shield up they're really
tricky yep super bruising I mean they
when we were creating this character we
really wanted to push the size of it and
scale them and really make them a little
bulkier so he reads completely different
than the other other Advent soldiers on
the field yeah and so the next one is
one of our favorites
that's the Archon he obviously is
inspired by the floater but completely
different he's beautiful where the flora
was a very ugly duckling so but again
we'll show what the Archon can do
blow stuff up
so yeah the arcon is evolution of the
florida a flying unit who has a lot of
tricks they still have like that floater
rage inside of them so when they take
damage they can go into a battle frenzy
which allows them to get an extra action
move really far they can strike you
melee with that staff which is really
deadly they can shoot it and then of
course they're their signature move is
called blazing pinions where they fly up
above the battlefield and then they
launch all these explosive shells and
attack all your units so they are a very
very very powerful unit and they're
beautiful too yeah I mean we're really
trying to go with sort of an in you know
some Egyptian influences and some some
all mostly a deity like we want him to
feel godlike and and even when he does
that move it is a very graceful
rage-filled contrast it's pretty pretty
awesome to see him in action
okay so
XCOM - coming out worldwide on February
5th and thank you all very much for
coming to Frank on for coming to our
panel and we're gonna have a lot of time
to hang out with you guys and talk
throughout today so thank you very much